and he gave me a book that's what I
tried yeah yeah that's why some people
are using cellophane if I do not really
follow it because they've noticed a lay
man attract them because Allah said the
messages
yeah
that's right that's right but also
what's happening now there's a new
ways they agree they will quote sellers
but it's implementation they don't
implement it
foreign
no I understand it exceptions
one thing really attracts me to them as
well
it has to go to other messages before
yeah if they show you in detail they're
not infallible they have their own
mistakes yeah but what I've noticed
about them you can see the
implementation of selfies
you can read the words of the scholars
the expression of the scholars and you
can see the implementation
implementation
guide him everywhere
you know that's why I always advise my
brothers and my sisters put something
aside read the books of the salad
read
um
he said if the self during their
lifetime they were stronger than me that
and they were very cautious who they're
gonna cooperate with who they're gonna
sit with what about our time I mean the
Alexander are small and I'll be there
are a lot so we have to be once more
cautious but doesn't mean everyone's
moved to death doesn't mean you work
with everyone
you have to be
depending on where they come from like
geography you have to be more cautious
and now for example someone comes from a
land which is known to the open
Innovation you have to maybe be a
different pushes if you know someone is
from somewhere where companies
fundamentally you believe that it's fine
yes yes so you there's a way to deal
with yourself
celebrities and anyway
give them more time yeah yeah you know
like even even we don't debate albida
it's not General
clowns
who's that at least I keep accepting
challenge it's gonna make some flowers
more like the other one is well
sometimes it's coming to ask questions
and if it's bringing down doesn't mean
it's evil to win because remember
this one maybe 25 years
you can't really move everything in one
hour
is stubborn this man is not wants to
listen sometimes they will be a bit
cheeky as well
you ask me questions ask the question
you know but